I'll finds out I have doubt i'm starting
my company but I'm 18 I think that
people won't take me seriously how can I
get over this hey Alfonso you gotta
believe it's behind Evan honestly you
believe there's a few things one social
media you can be whoever you want to be
in terms of social media you can build a
presence you can build a brand you can
build some products I think in the world
of social media the digital economy you
know great products win markets so if
you've got a product idea then you know
there's nothing stopping you if it's a
services business and it is even a
face-to-face business then I think
people looking to buy your enthusiasm
people have begun to buy your commitment
energy I know a couple of guys who are
young and they've gone in their sub 21
and they've started a services business
and they actually said what you know if
you believe what I say and I can do a
good job view I think I learned really
quickly i've got a great work ethic I go
great attitude why don't you take me on
for two weeks just unexpensive and pay
me nothing and then the end the doings
will prove ourselves and they've done
similar sort of thing with their people
so it's almost like try before you buy
so if you got any anxieties about being
16 years old I'm number one put them
away and number two is just build up
your confidence and conviction because
there's a lot of people who are 16 year
old now who are kind of changing the
world and just a couple of examples I
think there's a Forbes article about
someone mayor pen who's done with the
stuff she's given three ted talks I'm
started a load of stuff around a
clothing company and environmental
activist and wow the age was 16 it's
just incredible you just couldn't have
imagined that so I don't think age is a
barrier page is something you should
kind of think you got tremendous energy
tremendous passion you've got a big idea
people back you if you back yourself I
mean I can relate when I was 19 I had my
first software company and I was selling
the guys three times my age who had
peach DS and I didn't have a single
background you know in science and some
of the scientists and I took me a while
to get over it and I would try to do
everything by email I thought L if I
talk on the phone to know I'm too young
and and you know they won't take me
seriously and was until I realized that
these guys actually need me like I can
provide value to them and at the end of
the day that's all they care about all
they care about is can you help me with
the problem that I'm facing right now
and once I understood that then it gave
me a lot more confidence and be able to
talk to people even even later as i
started work with brains one of the
first companies that work with was
microsoft that was 20-something and i
thought wow i would Microsoft want to
work with me they're Microsoft they know
everything and I'm just some young punk
kid in and then I started talking I
realized oh ya know these guys these
guys need my help I can help them right
so just having confidence in your
abilities knowing that all they really
really deep down care about is that you
can provide value to them and help them
and once you understand that at least
for me that the age fear kind of went
away yeah and with Evan you know and I
know whatever age you are you could any
any really smart kids could go into a
business and improve it and you know
when you run a business for any period
of time you just are to become
complacent or you just do the same
things you do every day and I think this
complacency stifles innovation so people
accept the status quo and I just think
new pairs of eyes with tremendous
enthusiasm and no kind of just just
anxiety about changing stuff can make a
massive difference oh you know back
yourself believe in yourself and like
you even when I was 16 I was selling ice
creams on the beach front and I'll tell
you what it paid for my college
education I couldn't believe how much
margin there was a nice crease so these
are equivalent to Canadian it was
probably at the time this is a long time
ago is about dollar and I used to buy
this stuff in the ice cream and the cone
the actual unit price of these ice
creams was probably about to sin
I just couldn't believe the profit
margin and ice cream obviously there's
that you know if you didn't you didn't
hit it right it's a really hot day
there's a lot of wastage so it makes you
think about your margins and I be candid
with you guys when it was the kind of a
rainy day as a bad day no one came to
little booth on the seafront but what I
had to do was get out the booth and go
and sell my wares and sell the ice
creams to whoever was around and you
find out as well you know stuff happens
in your head to say you know people
aren't going to buy this they don't want
to talk to me their business or their
families but when you go up to people
and just have a conversation it's just
amazing how people are welcome in and
and people are want to buy stuff
especially from young people people back
young people people want young people to
be successful if you believe in yourself
that is contagious that belief and
conviction spreads like a beautiful
infection of love and you know what it's
like Evan the first one yourself the
second one it gets easier the third one
gets easier the fourth family you go up
to is easier everyone you do with all
these things just take the first step
believe in yourself back yourself have
no fear and then you just stopped
listening to those crazy voices in your
head but so you tell you you can't
because you can